[Music]
[Applause]
queen elizabeth is getting back in the
saddle well kind of the monarch made a
surprise appearance at the royal windsor
horse show which is said to be one of
her favorites
it marks her first public appearance
since march amid her ongoing health
issues but the queen looks happy and
healthy at the main event she was all
smiles in the crowd wearing a colorful
scarf over her head dark blue coat and
bringing the glam with some bright pink
lipstick and get this she also watched
part of the show from the comfort of her
range rover
i think we've been very lucky all these
years that the queen has been so visible
that she has been so many audiences in
person and she has had an incredible
energy that she has brought to her
public life but there without a doubt we
are seeing less of her we have seen her
carry out less public engagement more
virtual engagements one of those events
the queen attended virtually the opening
of parliament earlier this week it is my
understanding that the queen watched the
speech delivered by her son and from the
comfort of her sitting room at windsor
castle in a statement to et on monday
buckingham palace announced that she
missed the event due to episodic
mobility problems and after consulting
her doctors she decided not to attend
her son prince charles stepped in in her
place my lords and members of the house
of commons
her majesty's government's priority
is to grow and strengthen the economy
and help ease the cost of living for
families
it was a historic moment both for the
constitution for britain for the
monarchy to see prince charles deliver
the queen's speech on his mother's
behalf um
it did feel it did feel symbolic to see
the imperial crown there to see
the queen's throne seat empty to see
charles flanked by camilla everyone felt
the queen's absence very acutely today
she has not missed the state opening of
parliament in 59 years in fact she's
only ever missed it twice in her life
and with the queen's upcoming platinum
jubilee festivities this summer which
will celebrate her 70 years on the
throne it brings up the bigger question
how much will the queen publicly
participate
i think this expectation that we're
going to see the queen very visible and
very high profile during the platinum
jubilee is a little unrealistic and i
think people do forget because she is so
remarkable because up until now she has
always been so robust and she's enjoyed
such
such good help we do forget she's 96 we
forget that earlier this year she
suffered from covid a year ago she lost
her husband i think all of these factors
have taken have taken their toll and she
is now i think showing her age and
certainly beginning to feel her age
[Music]